[Music]
just 12 hours after the London Bridge
attack the Prime Minister was clear
where she thought the blame lies we
cannot allow this ideology the safe
space it needs to breed yet that is
precisely what the internet and the big
companies that provide internet-based
services provide as an extraordinarily
charged political statement so soon
after the attack from the Prime Minister
but it's also a vague one so let's break
it down into the three separate
technology issues that Theresa May is
talking about encryption is the
scrambling of messages so they can't be
read either by criminals or by the
police apps like whatsapp iMessage and
telegram all use encryption and soda
ecommerce and internet banking services
where we are trying to prevent or
pursuit terrorists there is going to be
a lawful basis for doing so and it's not
enough for companies to say oh well this
is encrypted because they know perfectly
well that they can alter their
algorithms to enable that material to be
intercepted where appropriate the
problem is creating a backdoor for the
UK government to exploit could also be
used by a foreign state like Russia for
example or by hackers as we saw with the
recent NHS cyberattack and because
encryption is based on pure mathematics
new services could spring up quickly
nearly all the big tech companies are
based in the United States that means
they obey US law not British that can
pose problems when law enforcement asks
for user data both the State Department
in the United States and the home office
in the UK need to be involved this is a
very very long-winded process and as
we've seen in in the past this can take
hundreds of days to service these
requests which is simply not at the pace
that is necessary for these
investigations
according to reports one of the London
Bridge attackers was radicalized online
by watching videos from this hate
preacher on YouTube he also has a
Facebook page the UK government has said
it once tech companies to do more to
remove this sort of content Google
Facebook and Twitter say they already do
a lot I do think that is something that
technology companies can do and it's by
looking at working in smaller
communities instead of just considering
the two billion people that use them
there are also groups that they can
interact with and try and not censor but
moderate and communicate with all of the
tech companies refused our request for
an interview there's a lot of confusion
in this debate and very little concrete
detail Tom Cheshire Sky News